A telephoto lens with the tripod for
your iPhone and soap
shaped like a piece of poop.
It's episode 23
of LÜT.
Wake up in your warm Nintendo knee-high
socks and put on your fancy superhero
bow-tie, along with these sunglasses from
Spencer's with a neat
hanging mustache.
Then, climb a rock wall
installed so that when you fall you just
take a dive. And this fire pit...
it's shaped like the world.
Squirrel mask.
Now, what's this?
Oh, nice
a Spock bath robe.
They've also got Captain Kirk,
but minimal superheroes now come on t-shirts.
Of course, this t-shirt makes you look rich.
Except by rich,
I mean geeky. I was kidding. Here's a
nice mug to get for your friend.
Again,
I was kidding. Keep the table safe with
giant Scrabble coasters
and keep your lips moist with unicorn
farts lip balm flavored like cotton
candy
and spearmint. These aren't for sale,
but check out normal stuffed animals
bought second-hand, inverted and then
made into cute inside-out cuddly animals.
You also can't buy this pancake quilt
with bacon accessory, because it's sold
out,
so keep the bacon sweet with VAT19's
bacon pops.
Hard candy infused with bacon bits
or be sweeter with a candy necklace
flavored like bacon.
Back to pancakes.
Williams-Sonoma offers molds to make Star Wars
shaped pancakes and if you have $50
and an out of this world taste, pick up some
exquisite gourmet chocolates
shaped like the planets.
Or
go darker with these anatomically
accurate skulls
made of chocolate. Here's a fluffy nuclear
mushroom cloud that's actually a lamp.
Shapeways.com
also offers a necklace sporting a loop
made of a single curl piece of metal
that locks in a ball or your very own strandbeest,
a sculpture, that when pushed or pulled
automatically appears to walk.
Oh, and this battle mug
has scope rail so you can soup it up
with all your equipment.
ThisIsWhyImBroke[.com]
pointed me toward a Zelda Sword USB Drive
and rage base masks.
Pop Chart Lab does it again with this amazing
graph poster of rap names organized by
common themes.
No, I've seen negatively engraved rings before,
but this one
from The Cheeky is great.
All day it pushes against your skin,
so when you try and be sneaky and remove it, your finger carries the mark
"I'm married."
TotusMel creates jewelry
with lace.
One of my favorites is the mask,
but don't forget the ankle corsets.
Drink some liquid from a can
that's actually a porcelain mug
and then solve puzzles
from V-CUBE.
Not six-sided six-colored ones,
but two-colored cubes that let you have
a checkerboard shape or my favorite
flag. With two colors, they've got
Poland, Denmark, Finland and Sweden,
but with three colors they've got Belgium, France, Germany, Hungary, Italy, Netherlands
and Russia.
Here's an eraser shaped like the evolution of man.
And Japan Trend Shop brings us Ten-Ten Dama.
Like a switch hit, an awesomely designed toy
that when thrown in the air seemingly
magically
inverts itself.
ThinkGeek has Captain Jules'
rings, which unfold into a telescope.
But now for your free thing.
Two things, actually. Cubeecraft[.com]
offers free printouts you cut, fold and
glue or tape in the fun characters and
shapes.
Once you've done that make them dance to Mario Paint
using the composer for PC or Mac just
like the one
in the original SNES game.
RezonerDJ recommended cyber dogs
cybernetic jewelry, like this headset.
And Tokyoflash
offers bizarrely awesome high-tech
watches that look like
things aliens have left behind.
Their newest is like a stencil. See, this one
says that it's 12:04.
As you may remember, 6 LÜTs ago
I mentioned them. Well, they found out,
thought it was awesome
and now they've set it up, so that until
the end of April if you buy a watch
using code VSTF you get ten dollars off.
So how about that?
Keep being Vsaucy.
And as always,
thanks for watching.